mathematics is a little bit like art and
a little bit like science and one of the
things that I really care about is
allowing people to kind of access both
elements of mathematics so on the one
hand we've got this beautiful structure
that can sometimes describe the world
and sometimes describe something that
we're thinking about that doesn't have a
representation in the real world and on
the other hand we have this powerful set
of tools that come from mathematics to
describe things that we see information
that we process when people get access
to that quantitative literacy they
become powerful citizens they can change
the way they think they can vote for
things they can advocate for things that
can make decisions about their own lives
in ways that are for informed by
quantitative information so if we don't
have information available to us we make
poor decisions and it's why we as a
society think it's really important that
people know how to read and for the same
reason we think it's really important
that people have access to quantitative
literacy so they can make informed
decisions about anything involving
quantitative information our medical
care our finances and that also includes
decisions that we make as a society
about our government in our health care
and our tax system so without
quantitative literacy we're driving in
the dark and with quantitative literacy
we are powerful advocates for ourselves
and for the values that we believe in
and I think as part of that we also get
a little access to the joy and the
beauty of mathematics